[موسيقى]
نحن الان في الايام الاولى من موسم
العقارب والعقارب مدته 39 يوما واذا انتهى
يبدا الشتاء الفعلي يلملم متاعه ليرحل عنا
والعقارب
ثلاثه عقربات السم بردوها قاتل مثل السم
وعقرب الدم بردها يدمي وعقرب الدسم
لتوائمها مع موسم الربيع وخلال مده
العقارب اللي هي 39 يوما يلسعنا البرد
ثلاث لسعات ولهذا سميت بالعقرب باقي على
البرد القارس ثلاث لسعات والعقارب من
الواسمه الهامه عندنا ليش لانها موسم غارس
الاشجار يابى فؤادي اي يميل الى الاذى حب
الاذيه من طباع
العقرب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وفصول السنه عند العرب القدماء صيف وشتاء
لايلاف قريش ايلافهم رحله الشتاء والصيف
وهذه الفصول تحتوي بين دفتيها على موسمي
الخريف والربيع فالربيع يولد من رحمه
الشتاء ولهذا الاصل فيها البروده والخريف
يولد من رحم الصيف ولهذا الاصل فيه
الحراره والربيع لا يولد الا بتعسر غبار
واتربه وتقلبات جويه قد بدلت دهر صفو
العيش بالكادري وبدل العين بعد النوم
بالسهر لا اي شيء يصفو من الدنيا التي
طبعت على الدمار فلم تبقي ولم
[موسيقى]